my guest this week has been described as
one of the greatest English soccer
Strikers of all time as a player Gary
lineker scored 48 goals for England and
nearly 250 for English clubs since
leaving the pitch he's become the face
of football coverage here in the UK and
is a big vocal presence on social media
when I sat down with him ahead of the
World Cup I wanted to ask him about
concerns to do with qatar's human rights
record the likes of David Beckham doing
deals with the state and why footballers
can never win
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for being here
pleasure lovely to have you thank you
and it's an interesting time to talk to
you because normally before a World Cup
there'd be a lot of the usual feelings
excitement trepidation this feels quite
different because of the controversy
around where it is
um believe you me this is the same
before every World Cup there are
different levels of it and this is high
level but you can go back
you go back to 1934 if you want and the
World Cup was in Italy and it was used
as a vehicle to promote fascism for
Mussolini so we're not this is not new
um Brazil in 2014 we were all there were
riots on the streets by by people in
Brazil saying they shouldn't spend all
this money on the stadiums they should
spend it on social care we had Russia
who invaded um Crimea just a few years
before
um before they hosted the World Cup so
it's not something we're unaccustomed to
do you think it's on a different scale
though because some of the reports of
course about the number of lives that
have been lost in the building of the
the stadium and the preparations
I think what makes this different as not
just in terms of Human Rights and
um obviously workers rights and what
happened to them and lots of lives were
lost in the in the building of of
Stadium I think what is really different
about this one is that we know when the
bid was proved to be successful
that it was corrupt so I think that's
what perhaps separates this from the
rest human rights wise well there's a
few countries that have hosted it that
would would fail some tests on that yeah
well let's go to that in a minute but on
the FIFA point because the former FIFA
president sep blatter has now said it
was a mistake it waited a long time to
do that yeah I mean not in the clearest
could have told him that the the minute
he would open the thing that said Qatar
on it I mean do you think there's any
value in in that statement at this point
or is it just pointless to hear it I I
just don't understand why I would do
that now I don't know whether that helps
or hinders or or what I mean he's he's
you know he's the ex president of FIFA
um at a time where there was a lot of
dodgy goings on so I
yes it was a mistake but it was more
than a mistake wasn't it really well I
mean also FIFA just having put out this
email let's not focus on the politics
let's focus on the football do you think
FIFA has learned as a body about what's
the important thing I do believe that
the current I should you know maybe I'm
being naive but I do believe the current
people in charge
um of FIFA and it includes arsene Wenger
is in a really high role I have certain
amount of faith and trust that arsenang
is a decent upstanding non-corrupt
person so I don't think the levels of
corruption if there are any but there
will be in certain branches of FIFA
because it goes it's Global and but in
terms of the very top I think it's it's
much more transparent the voting system
is much more transparent and there's
less corruption do they still make
mistakes yes they do
um in terms of things that they said and
that the thing you just mentioned was
was very tone deaf to say that because
there's no question that this is
kind of sports washing but the reason
Sports washing works is when you are
told to shut up about everything else
and just say we'll just stick to the
football
so I think I think that was a that was
an error and I think it was a tone deaf
statement and I think it's something
that most of the federations have I will
probably argue against some of the
players we've heard might be wearing
armbands in support of lgbtq players and
people around the world do you think we
should hear more from the players
themselves well I think it's really
interesting isn't it because the minute
players stand up and voice their
concerns everyone sells them stay out of
politics stick to football yeah when
they don't stand up and say something
people say why aren't you saying
anything so there's a there's an element
of the footballers that can't win on
this
I they're inextricably linked politics
and Sport All Sport there's there's no
um getting away from that fact
politicians will use football when it
suits them so if england start doing
well and they get to the court if I was
a semi-final you will all have our
politicians standing up and they'll be
putting England jerseys on and
pretending to be really interesting now
some of them are interested in football
a lot of them aren't but even the ones
that aren't will suddenly be wanting to
be seen and jump on this this England
bandwagon of success
um but the minute
footballers voice themselves and or come
out and talk about social issues take
Marcus rashford for example take the
captains during covid all of a sudden
it's like well hang on a minute you're
getting a bit above your station here so
footballers are allowed to speak
um when it suits the politicians I
always feel it's always been a little
bit of a kind of pet hate of mine or of
course though the people they answer to
are their fans as well so yes the
politicians make the statements and get
the airtime in response but I suppose
it's just also it's been striking how
some of the female players have spoken
out female football players about it I
was looking at the comments from
England's lotta women Moyer who said
she's not going to watch it Beth Mead of
course it's hugely successful uh Striker
she's done so well in the game she's
just winning all these accolades she's
gay herself she said it's just so
disappointing but it's quite a big thing
to say you're not going to watch it when
you play football for a living
um yeah yeah I mean people make their
own own decisions on what what they have
to do um I just wanted you think they're
being Bolder because they're not
involved yeah of course yeah I mean it's
very easy to say these things if you're
not if you're not going to play in the
world you're not going to play in it
it's a different thing do you think
footballers get scared about speaking
out I get nervous I think some will some
won't some are brave some have stand up
I've been really proud of footballers
over the last few years I think they've
really come out on social issues I've
mentioned rashford before the captain's
doing the thing we've seen people like
Raheem Sterling speak out brilliantly on
racism things like that so I've been
really proud of the fact and a lot of
them do and a lot of them will others
are less comfortable and it's it's for
me it's purely personal issue I don't
you know if somebody wants to take a
stand in a certain way
that's fine and if if somebody just
wants to concentrate on their game and
their own probably possibly their only
opportunity to play in a World Cup they
just want to get on with the football
side of it and not let these things
creep in that's fine too you've talked a
bit about because just to say very
clearly it's it's homosexuality is
illegal
there are also other issues that are are
very different culturally for the fans
which perhaps will come on to but you've
also talked about it would be a moment
not to put pressure but it would be a
bit of a moment if a footballer came out
as gay well during this time I did say
that but I didn't I didn't say a
footballer should I know the context is
important so I was saying it would be a
you know big you know kind of middle
finger to perhaps that thing it won't
happen I wouldn't put pressure on any
player ever to do that anyway
um but of course it's of course it's an
issue the human rights side of things it
has to be a Qatar World Cup Ambassador
has just called homosexuality damage in
the mind
uh which is an insight into the view the
reason for the view
um if you were gay as a fan would you go
to this tournament it's a great question
I I don't know because because it's it's
it's it's a hypothetical question um I
would you would have to give it a lot of
thought I think
um you know I saw one of their main
Representatives I think it was altani
speaking in an interview saying that
that you know people gay people will be
welcome if and the question was asked
what about the walk down the street
holding hands he said that would be
absolutely fine
but let's see but there's a risk but I
understand why people
um if you know the lgbtq ETC would would
have reservations and thoughts and
concerns absolutely whether I you could
say whether I would go if I were gay I I
honestly don't know I don't know I mean
you obvious you are going to work too
I'm going to work yeah yeah
um how are you feeling about that with
this no I'm fine but I don't have the
scientist problem about going to work
I'm not going there to support the World
Cup being in Qatar I'm going there to
report yeah for me that's that's my job
as a kind of sports broadcasted
journalist yeah um as you know
journalists will be sent to to the war
with Russia and Ukraine but it doesn't
mean to say they support no no no and I
didn't mean that but I meant more like
if there was any nervousness you know
just things like qatar's UK ambassadors
warned against public displays of
affection I'm not saying you're going to
be doing uh any affection with your
money
but but also for the fans I wonder if
you've got nervousness about that not
just on the human rights side but the
zero tolerance for drinking in public
and being drunk I know
well I I always have concerns about
English fans traveling abroad because
I'm afraid of small as you know small
percentage of them do go there looking
for trouble looking to just get drunk
looking for a fight
um and that's been part of something
that has I've just been detestable
around the England squad for years and
they've ruin it for everyone else
um what will happen to them in Qatar I
don't know if if they go along that
things but I think we've all I think all
football fans obviously in their ranks
have the drinking side yeah yeah well
yeah it's a nervousness perhaps around
the whole thing as well I'm sure I'm
sure I mean I think we'll all be
thinking ourselves how do we get a drink
at some point there might be that as
well
um many footballers as yourself become
pandits ambassadors journalists
commentators there has also been
criticism of for instance David Beckham
becoming a paid ambassador to Qatar head
of the World Cup he's got to promote
tourism and culture and Qatar he's
become a face of it what do you make of
that sort of decision well that's a
that's again it's a personal decision
I'm not going to sit here and be
judgmental would I do it no
um Eric Canton I obviously played with
him has spoken out and urged him to
think yeah differently yeah and and I
understand why he's done that and um as
I said would I have done it no he's
decided to go down that route I would
say about David he's never really voiced
his concerns about where the World Cup
is about
um so I you know it's not something he's
ever got involved in so can you accuse
him but he's not hypocritical
um if I'd have done it I'd have I was
very very anti the bid when it was first
revealed in 2010 I was in the room I
couldn't believe it it seemed to me that
it it must have been corrupt because
they were talking about staging a summer
World Cup in Qatar where temperatures
are in the 40s sometimes even
approaching 50 degrees Centigrade it
seemed unfathomable so it did then
obviously latterly it was moved to
Winter are and I was very vocal against
it so if I was going to do something
like that I'd feel hypocritical I don't
think you could accuse Beckham of that
you might accuse him of doing something
that
you might feel is fundamentally a wrong
thing to do and a lot of people will
think that are you disappointed by him
doing that though because he's a role
model
um
as I said I wouldn't I wouldn't do it I
think also people think why does he need
10 million quid does he really need to
do that that's the other question I mean
I don't I have no idea how much he's
getting paid but I I suspect I suspect
it it would survive without it
so I suppose it's that you know the the
feeling of of influence and how how
people have influence and what they use
of course you know football is a you
know
it become right obviously Sports a
massive thing in the whole world anyway
football particular and just before a
World Cup
um it is and there's a lot of expectancy
on on footballers but you know every
there's a lot of criticism about how
much they earn stuff like that and
footballers do get it in the neck it's
like it's it's
it's tough to win obviously they have a
wonderfully lucrative life
but it's funny I always think they don't
really get the criticism in other people
with in other sports even like you know
you got that earn lots of money like
golf or formula one or you could even go
in other routes like actors huge actors
get the earned fortunes musicians
brilliant musicians they are if you're
in the entertainment industry you do get
paid a lot of money but no one else gets
that football it's it's almost as though
it's it's all these are working class
Lads it's a little bit is that what you
think I genuinely believe it might be
subconsciously but I think there's an
element of that they're a bit above
their station is it also because they
can and do especially because they're so
young earning so much money get into a
lot of trouble at times like many of
them do not many of them do so yeah and
the other thing as well it is absolutely
a perception thing footballers are a
cross-section of working class Society
really they come up and it's hard they
have to work really hard they live very
well every now and again a football will
misbehave one out of a you know the
thousands of them around you know and
every but that becomes a huge story all
the incredible good that they do for the
like local communities visiting kids in
hospital doing loads of good things
raising awareness of whether it be
racism or join the covid pandemic that
doesn't become the big story but what
you know one player goes out in a
drunken night out and gets pictured with
a girl or something then that becomes
like a front page story and it's and
it's a little bit unfair and that
doesn't really happen as much in other
areas it's a disproportionate I think
it's disproportionate yeah I mean of
course when access you know behave badly
or things it also gets captured but it's
interesting to hear you think it is
disappointed I mean we should also say
there have been some really high profile
cases and allegations made against Top
Class footballers in relation to
Behavior with women on the surface it
seems a a change in the culture when you
were playing around the game I don't
know if that that's fair and what what
you think about that I don't know I just
I still cool thing even when I played I
doubt it's that much different now you'd
you'd have a lot more money I suppose
well there is a lot of people not
settling there is a lot more money and
there'd be a lot more you know dangers
and and outside interests I I honestly
think that mostly though like the
massive majority of footballers would be
really good lads well behaved
work really really hard on what they do
and live properly because you have to
now because it's so competitive and I
think it was exactly the same in my day
you will still get the odd drunk the odd
sexist the odd homophobic person they
are like a cross-section of working
class society and the odd person that
will commit a crime
um so but it's it's not Rife you know
it's it's like it's very occasionally
limited and
I'm not trying to defend the actions
I'm trying to get context and
perspective of the overall picture of
footballers I suppose though the other
thing that's undeniable is we still
don't have an openly gay male footballer
in the Premier League
what could could change or how could
that change do you think to to make that
a space where it feels comfortable I
don't know I mean it's again and it's
I mean it is it's distressing and we've
seen it starting to see it in other
sports aren't we but you know Tom Daley
we've seen and um well in the women's
game the women's women's game as well
and I I just would love it if we had an
environment where they just felt they
should it seems absurd that anyone
should because
Society thing as well I mean I I kind of
probably naively said something in an
interview recently they got picked up by
quite a lot of few like smart gay people
which I've kind of learned from I was
saying I honestly think that if a
footballer came out it would be hugely
positive and others would follow and
they and they you know I was kind of
told you know don't just leave no idea
how difficult this situation is
um so I mean it's delicate um and it's
and it's true it's it's kind of baffling
because it's obvious there must be
um lots of Premier League footballers
and footballers around the country that
that are gay and having to to live
not that true and not be their true
selves and I think that's that's really
sad did you like looking back on your
career do you think you played alongside
man who who weren't their true selves in
that way oh yeah I think so I think so
I'm pretty sure I don't know for a fact
but
um I think so I know do you have young
footballers you come to you so I I've
had a couple both Anonymous actually
um one was um
one was very close to coming out we
would
he was actually the secret gay
footballer and he was I was talking to
him on direct message quite a lot and I
was going to be doing
um the interview when
um but then he got cold feet at the last
second and I said I totally respect that
I totally understand and then I was
reached out through my agency another
anonymous football that was thinking
about it so I don't know who they are
but they're out there of course they're
out there and I can understand how
incredibly difficult it must be do you
think it's the fans mainly I don't know
I don't know I it's it's probably
everything you know it's they're kind of
come in who knows that might not have
told their family they might they might
be scared about that they might be
scared about telling their teammates in
the dressing room yeah I don't I it must
be it must be quite incredibly difficult
tough
on your coming out with your political
views a different type of coming out and
saying more what you think uh about
things it actually did take you a long
time didn't it it took social media is
that what it I mean I've always had to
you know I'd know where to know where to
share them and I think you know I
when you speak out like that there are
people who who don't like the reactions
and have ended up then self-censoring do
you ever have that fear that anxiety
after you've sent the post I have I have
a policy with with I've got three rules
in Twitter one is not to tweet when I'm
had a few drinks which I'd stick to
um the other is not to tweet if I'm
angry but I don't really get angry so
the but you know when I'm too frustrated
and my other one is that whenever I do
any kind of tweet I'll read it back
and then if I have one percent doubt I
won't send it it's gone although that
one occasionally when I think think of
something that I think actually that's
quite funny
I'll take a chance but generally they're
my three rules would you pay for your
authentication I wouldn't have paid 44
billion for Twitter
well I never asked for it in the first
place no no but the whole idea of how
they're going to change a model pay yeah
I don't know yet I'm going to weigh it
up I'm not gonna make any rash decision
now instead I mean you know it's not
it's not but the truth is actually most
I mean a lot of people are on Twitter to
follow people that they find interesting
whether they're mostly Blue Tick peoples
whether they're like a politician or
actor or a sports person or a musician
or you've or real Comedians and you
follow them
and they're the Blue Tick ones so
actually I think it's the Blue Tick
people that entice more people onto the
platform so Elon Musk I think should be
paying us eight dollars a month everyone
on there rather than the other way
around well you can tweet him direct
because he replies it seems to
absolutely all right especially if
you've got a Bluetooth I doubt it'd
agree with me though I dare you to tweet
um you mentioned of course the the
reaction to football as former
footballers like yourself uh from
politicians at times and I you brought
up the pandemic as well and um here in
the UK the former Health secretary Matt
Hancock uh when asked about football is
Wages during the lockdown during the
pandemic said quote everybody needs to
play their part in this National effort
and that means Premier League
footballers too he talked about taking
pay cuts you'll remember all this he's
now in Australia taking part in a
reality TV show called I'm a celebrity
get me out of it been suspended as a
conservative MP do you think he's
playing his part as an MP I think he
should have stuck to telling footballers
to stick to football
yes I mean I did do what he wants but
he's still an acting politician so it
seems a bit strange to me to disappear
into the jungle but I think maybe I did
you see that thing when um Richie sunak
was welcomed and he shook everyone's
hand and he kind of ignored Hancock in
the middle yes and I maybe that maybe
that was it I'm going to bloody jungle
it might also be the 400 Grand that he's
been maybe that might be that that's one
of the 400 000 reasons for him going on
we don't know I don't know if he's
getting that but they do pay well
apparently apparently so but I suppose
it was what you were talking about
earlier about who stays in which lane
and and who polices who of course and
with with politicians I always find it
it depends that they'll do it when it
suits them yes well and then and then of
course there are those who feel you know
very passionately that our politicians
shouldn't be celebrities and shouldn't
be reaching for that because they're
public servants and and then there's
very serious points about him going in I
suppose from those who were bereaved
during the pandemic and feel indeed I
can understand people's reservations
about it um it's almost a kind of bit of
comedy in a way isn't it but there are
obviously more serious issues that he
was you know he was a large part of of
the early days with you know
there's so many deaths in covid and some
you know labor some would throw the the
blame at the government in terms of the
the lack of protection certainly in Care
Homes and things like that so I've
that's your equivalent of taking some of
these other deals perhaps yeah I think
so big I don't know it'd be my worst
night thank you so much for talking to
me pleasure and thank you so much for
being with us until we meet again take
care and goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]